this is tamo hussein reading for
reviewer jason fennelly throughout the
years the fighting game has proven to be
one of the most versatile genres much of
that versatility comes through guest
characters from the walking dead's
villain turned anti-hero negan joining
tekken 7 to super smash brothers
ultimate all-star cast with dnf duel arc
system works ups the ante on this idea
taking an entire game nexon's
long-running mmo dungeon fighter online
and building a fresh fighting game with
it the result is a solid brawler that
despite a mediocre story boasts a varied
roster near flawless online play and a
fighting game system with plenty of
options for newcomers and seasoned
veterans alike
dnf duel is set in the world of dungeon
fighter online sure but prior knowledge
of that game is not required to jump
into this one the source material is
mostly referential serving as a backdrop
for the overarching story and characters
each of these characters is built from
one of the mmo's playable classes some
of the characters look like they were
pulled from another fighting game the
grappler for instance is a dark-haired
hand-to-hand fighter wearing a martial
arts uniform which sounds familiar
others like the ghost blade and
berserker stand out thanks to their
incredible and intimidating look the
berserker's red eyes spiky blonde hair
and scaly red arm make him look like an
evil super saiyan while the ghost blade
is doubly scary thanks to the ethereal
black beast floating over his body like
a stand from jojo's bizarre
adventure fighting system in dnf duel is
the epitome of easy to learn hard to
master moves are performed by combining
single directions with attack buttons
akin to the control scheme in super
smash bros normal attacks can be
performed with no restriction while
special moves pull from a finite amount
of mp scene in a blue bar below the
character's health mp restores over time
but using a move that requires more mp
than is available will put the character
into an exhaustion state delaying mp
regeneration and weakening attacks for a
short period this sounds pretty standard
and honestly that's a good thing it
makes for a low barrier of entry for new
players to the fighting game genre
[Music]
however that simplicity sits on top of a
slew of moving parts that increase the
learning curve significantly there are
two mechanics in dnf deal that are
fundamental to success conversion and
awakening conversion is an advanced
mechanic that casual players might not
even realize is available unless they
accidentally trigger it conversion lets
a player spend their white health which
is health that has been lost but within
the window of where it can be
regenerated in order to cancel all
movement and restore mp the amount
restored depends on how much white
health was spent this leads to longer
combos that inflict more damage but
using it at the wrong time will leave
you wide open for counter attacks
using it is easy enough the right bumper
or r1 will activate it in a single
button press but ultimately conversion
isn't something a casual player will see
from ai opponents or beginners ranks
online
if you're going to learn dnf duel it's
essential but if you're just here for
the dfo references and something
different to play it won't affect you
much awakening however is the more
universal mechanic of the two occurring
when a character drops to 30 percent
health awakening not only gives access
to super powerful awakening attacks but
also provides a boost unique to each
character swift masters awakening state
boost his movement speed for example
while the ranger can inflict a debuff on
an opponent with every hit while
awakening doesn't sound unique the added
twist of giving each character a unique
boost makes the mechanic much more
effective the challenge is figuring out
how everything hair links together
thereby creating flashy and super
damaging combos while staying within mp
limits to avoid exhaustion each
character is a giant puzzle with each
piece being a different attack
conversion opportunity or key movement
the in-game tutorials do a good job of
giving you ideas the combo trials are
made specifically for this but there's
much more fun to be had experimenting in
free training it helps that every
character's fighting style is unique as
well that variety goes a long way in
keeping the game feeling fresh but that
also means learning 16 different
movesets if you're trying to master
every character it's a steep learning
curve but that feeling of executing a
combo in the heat of battle is pure
adrenaline after finding your main
character and mastering them the game
offers plenty to do outside of training
and tutorials arcade mode is
self-explanatory a gauntlet of matches
leading up to a powerful final boss just
like in the old arcade days story mode
gives some context to each character
through cut scenes but ultimately the
mode plays out much like arcade does
for a game referencing nearly two
decades of source material i expected a
more robust story mode akin to other arc
system works like dragon ball fighters
or guilty gear strive instead each
character fights eight battles with some
cutscenes sprinkled in i did appreciate
how some keywords were highlighted
during cutscenes and i could press a
button mark glossary to learn what those
terms meant ultimately though the story
mode is disappointing and more
importantly it's a massive missed
opportunity for someone like me who's
never played dfo to learn more about it
the best experience dnf deal has to
offer however is online the fighting
game genre as a whole has seen some
tumultuous times when it comes to online
play with a delay-based netcode of old
making some games unplayable without
perfect network conditions dnf duel is
among a new breed of online fighters
employing what is called rollback
netcode due to how it handles frame
delay between two players and the
difference is night and day playing dnf
deal online is like having the person in
the room with you with no interruption
in the action throughout a match across
numerous online matches both in ranked
and unranked matchmaking every battle
played out without a single technical
issue how i personally performed in
those online matches is a different
story but hey it's a steep learning
curve arc system works continues to set
a high standard for fighting games with
dnf deal creating an experience that's
both simple enough for new players and
robust enough for fighting game veterans
16 unique characters offer plenty of
variety the core fighting game systems
reward players who dig into it and the
online offering feels like an arcade
scene of old i would have preferred a
more in-depth story mode but the rest of
what the game brings more than makes up
for the misstep dnf duo not only excels
as a fighting game but it also
reinforces the versatility of the entire
genre through its adaptation of an
established ip into a whole new
experience
[Music]